ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Well, it's
great to see everybody talking
and getting to know each other.
And it's a lot of energy,
positive energy in the room.
It's really great to see.
So now we'd like to start
our next faculty panel.
We have three
tenured faculty who
are going to give some
good advice on navigating
your professional
path as a scholar.
So I'd like to
introduce them now.
They'll each speak again
for about 10 minutes,
and then we'll open it up
to questions and discussion.
So I'll start with
Julie Buckler, who
is a professor of Slavic
and comparative literature
in the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences.
She also currently holds
a half-time position
as the humanities director
of academic ventures
at the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study.
Julie received her doctorate
in Slavic from Harvard
and has spent her academic
career here, appointed
as a junior professor,
assistant professor in 1996
and awarded tenure
by the faculty
of Arts and Sciences in 2003.
She works on the literature,
performing arts, cultural life,
and urban environments
of Russia,
with a focus on the imperial
period and its legacies.
For the past
several years, Julie
has also been a central member
of the steering committee
of the humanities
project, which works
to foster arts and
humanities initiatives that
build intellectual
community and integrate
the humanities
into urban studies
more broadly as it is
practiced in the fields
of urban planning,
design, architecture,
the social sciences,
and public policy.
We have Darren Higgins, who
is a professor of microbiology
and immunobiology at
the medical school.
He holds a PhD in
microbiology and immunology
from the University of
Michigan Medical School
and completed his
postdoctoral studies
at the University of
Pennsylvania School of Medicine
and the University of
California at Berkeley.
Darren came to the
Harvard Medical school
as an assistant
professor in 1999
and was promoted to professor
with tenure in 2009.
His laboratory currently
focuses on understanding
fundamental host pathogen
interactions that
lead to virulence
in the development
of protective immunity
to intracellular
bacterial pathogens.
He's also the inventor
on several patents
and co-founded and serves
on the Scientific Advisory
Board of Genocea
Biosciences, Inc.,
a company that commercializes
key breakthroughs in vaccine
discovery and development
with a focus on intracellular
pathogens.
And we have a Devah Pager, who
is a professor of sociology
in the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences
and a professor of public
policy at the Kennedy School.
She's also the Susan S.
and Kenneth L. Wallach
Professor at the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study
and the director of the
Harvard Multi-Disciplinary
Program in Inequality
and Social Policy Devah
holds a PhD from the University
of Wisconsin at Madison
and was a Fulbright
Fellow in Paris,
studying changes in crime policy
and patterns of immigration
and ethnic tension in
contemporary France.
Her research focuses on
institutions affecting
racial stratification,
including education,
labor markets, and the
criminal justice system.
Her field experiments
investigate
racial and economic consequences
of large-scale imprisonment
and discrimination against
minorities and ex-offenders
in contemporary
US labor markets.
So again, welcome
to our panelists.
And maybe we start with
Julie for some sound advice.
JULIE BUCKLER: Can you hear me?
Yes?
Well, welcome.
Welcome to Harvard.
I hope you'll be happy here and
this place will be good to you.
I've been here for
a really long time.
I've been on the faculty
since 1996, as Elizabeth said.
I was hired as a freshly minted
PhD, the ink on my degree
not even dry, no postdoc,
nothing, just dived right in.
And I was tenured in 2003.
And my tenure, I think,
came at the beginning,
in the early years of a big
wave of internal promotions
such that there's
quite a cohort of us
now who are tenured from within
by support of departments
and mentored by colleagues
and given sound advice.
And I'm very grateful to
those who had helped me.
I'd like to share with you some
wisdom that I have acquired
in my now 19 years
on the faculty
here, both as a junior person
and as a tenured person.
And also, now being 12
years out from tenure,
I feel like I've learned
a few things about what
it's like to be senior.
And I know that this
audience consists mostly
of junior tenure-track faculty
but that there are also
some senior hires here.
And welcome.
And so I'm going to offer
some advice to both groups
since I now have some
thoughts on that.
So for junior faculty, now,
of course, everything I say
comes from my experience
in the humanities.
So I apologize if some of
it isn't pertinent to people
in other fields.
In the humanities,
the old standard,
the old gold standard
was two books by tenure.
And that's a lot in a
seven-year junior appointment.
But I did it, because--
SPEAKER 1: You're choking.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE BUCKLER: And then I had to
get over my post-tenure stress
syndrome.
I did it because
it had to be done.
It was made very
clear to me that that
was what it was going to
cost me to be considered
for promotion, to be considered
seriously for promotion.
I think the standards
are more flexible
and more broadly defined now.
And I think that's
very positive.
I kind of would have
liked not to have written
my second book in such a rush.
But that's OK.
At least I wrote it.
So my advice is this
to junior faculty.
The junior appointment
seems like it's
going to be very long, but
it's actually very short.
And it's really important
to get control of your time.
to have a master plan.
Sit down and really
give some thought
to what you would
like to be able to put
on the table the year
you come up for review.
And then really think about
how you're going to get there.
But most of the things that
you want to have to show,
you're going to
build up in stages.
And so you need to
plan the staging,
plan the multiple talks, the
course, the new acquaintances,
the collaborators,
et cetera, that
are going to lead you
to the publications
that you want to have.
Harvard is renewing itself very
much in the area of teaching.
We have the Harvard Initiative
for Learning and Teaching.
We have HarvardX, and really
good and innovative teaching
is highly valued here now, as
is significant service, program
building and other ways of
really serving what we do.
That said, your
publication record
is still the most important
thing in your dossier.
And so it's very
important that you don't
let it get lost in the shuffle.
So look for the
synergies, and then be
very conscious
about the decisions
you make regarding the
projects you invest in deeply,
having educated
yourself about the view
that Harvard tends to
take on these things.
So in my field, for example,
doing an extensive translation
of poems by a particular
poet with a long scholarly
introduction is certainly
a worthy project but one
that most people
would probably think
was better done after
you were tenured.
And you may decide to go ahead
and do that translation project
anyway as a junior person, but
you should at least understand
the choice that you're making.
And you might get tenure,
too, but just-- so
let your senior colleagues tell
you what the expectations are,
and make your own decisions
based on your own priorities.
January is now a huge boon.
The academic calendar
changed a few years ago,
and now January for faculty
is heaven, pretty much.
Fall semester is over, spring
semester hasn't started,
and you can kind of lay low
and really get some work done.
It never used to be possible to
get any of your own work done
during the academic
year, I mean, except
for little bits and pieces.
So I'm just a
proponent of getting
your tools set in
order, whatever you use,
bibliographic management,
presentation software.
Be proactive and
entrepreneurial.
Organize things
yourself so that you
can be on the panels
you want to be on.
Apply for a Radcliffe
exploratory seminar,
run a talk series at one of
the centers with a colleague.
All of these can be
done collaboratively,
but they're all good ways to
extend your reach at Harvard
without overextending yourself.
And so my best piece of
advice is do get out there.
See if you can get an
interesting service
assignment or two.
I was on the freshman
seminar committee
when the freshman seminar
program expanded a lot,
and it was a wonderful
committee assignment,
because I got to see these
really wonderful proposals
and syllabi from all
across the university.
And I learned a lot,
and I thought a lot,
and we had great discussions.
And I was just very happy that I
agreed to be on that committee.
And so you can't allow yourself
to be completely bunkered
in your own department.
It won't be good for you here.
But you also can't be
running around all the time
and never sitting down and
getting down to business.
And for teaching preparation,
I recommend top-down planning.
It took me years to
figure out that the best
way to prepare to teach was
not to read everything and take
an enormous number
of pages of notes
so that I would feel I
had mastery of the topic
and then come into class.
Much better to do top-down
planning, really thinking
about what you
want to accomplish
during each class,
what the goals are,
and kind of filling
in that way, top down.
That way you don't
waste a minute,
and you don't need to be
your own best student,
if you know what I mean.
So that's my best advice
for junior people.
Keep your head down,
but not too much.
Make a plan.
Really make a plan
and keep track of it.
Keep yourself honest.
Use all the tricks they talk
about in business books on how
to be more effective.
Don't look at email for certain
hours of the day, reserve
one day a week to stay home
and work on your own stuff
if you can, et cetera.
My advice for senior faculty
is somewhat different.
When you're tenured, you will
accrue a pretty heavy service
load, because that's who can
do a lot of the work-- task
forces, promotion reviews,
searches, chairing departments.
The list goes on and on.
And it's important.
And when you get
tenure, you kind of
owe it to Harvard to
pitch in on that stuff.
But you can also get
buried by the work.
So I've found that collaborative
projects have worked really
well for me during this
stage in my career,
because they allow me to invest
in projects I really care about
and to advance
them because I have
partners who are helping me.
That's working
really well for me.
I'm also really interested
in nontraditional forms
of scholarly output,
like websites,
and I'm especially
enamored right now
for a virtual exhibition
software tool called Omeka.
It's kind of a
repository, and it
allows students to do more
than write traditional papers.
It allows them to do more
with design and presentation
and to incorporate
different media.
I find it's more
engaging for students.
And I also find that it's
a nice and tempting format
for my own scholarly production
but not something I would have
attempted as a junior person.
So when you're
senior, you have to be
kind of cagey about
finding ways to advance
your projects while also
doing the things you're
supposed to do.
And other people swear
by writing groups,
by having trusted peers
who read their work,
by setting up networks,
connections, commitments
that are going to support you
in getting your own work done.
You can't just wait for, live
for your next sabbatical.
You can be making small
deposits in your piggy bank
for the four years leading
up to a sabbatical.
That's what I've done.
And just keep
socking stuff away.
Keep buying books.
Keep files of things.
Give the same talk several
times but in different venues
or from a different perspective.
I mean, things take such
a long time to develop,
so allow that space
for it to happen.
So that's my best advice.
Those are my hard-won truths.
I think you can really
thrive and prosper here,
but you have to make the
institution work for you.
Because it is a very
fast-paced, and there's
just an enormous
amount going on.
You have to stay grounded.
So best of luck.
And I mean that
sincerely, not ironically.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
DARREN HIGGINS: I'll
pick up from there.
And I unfortunately
didn't get a chance
to see the previous
session, but I
think a lot of things that
all the panelists will say
will resonate and
cross boundaries.
So I'm at the medical school.
And as the intro said, I'm
starting my 17th year here.
And unlike the humanities, I
do very little formal teaching.
I was hired to come and
set up a research lab
and basically have productive,
scholarly work in terms
of papers, in terms of
research development.
And that was sort
of my primary goal.
I also came at a time,
which is, I think, less
of a kinder, gentler time.
And it certainly has changed.
And I just want to
say at the beginning,
I have one theme throughout
the 10 minutes I'll speak,
and that's basically,
don't work in a bubble.
Don't work in a vacuum.
And I'll try to interject kind
of some practical strategies
of how to actually do that and
follow from what Julie said.
And I remember when I first came
here as assistant professor,
I was like, OK, go in
and get your lab set up,
and go get your R01
grants, and just go to it.
And I remember sitting about
three months after I showed
up back in 1999, and
I thought to myself,
I could die in my office today.
Nobody would know.
[LAUGHTER]
Nobody would care--
--until the smell permeated
far enough down the hallway
that someone said, go
figure out what's going on.
And I remember I had this
candy dish in my office,
so when people came
it was like, hey,
do you want to sit and
have a talk and talk to me?
[LAUGHTER]
And usually it was
someone saying,
oh, we heard you had
this piece of equipment.
You don't have it.
Goodbye.
And so I realized at that point
that working in the bubble
and trying to do everything on
your own isn't going to work.
And I said, well, how
do I get out of this?
And one of the
things I'll cross to
is people talk about mentorship.
And I really think you have
to develop multiple mentors
and think of your career as if
you were the general contractor
of your career.
And you don't have to do
everything perfectly, but find
the people that do
things really well
and lock onto those individuals
to get good, sage advice.
I remember I called my
graduate mentor, who
was a very engaging
person, who is now
a dean at Michigan State.
And he says, well,
what you need to do
is just engage the other
faculty, get out there,
and I know you a little bit,
so just go ask them to lunch.
Because everyone has to eat.
And do something
to break the ice.
And I remember I asked all
my senior faculty to lunch,
and I was very nervous.
And I spoke to people.
Mostly I told him about
what I did a little bit.
I'm doing this.
OK, great.
And about two months later,
a student comes to my office
and says, oh, I want to talk to
you about rotating in your lab.
I went to one of your
senior colleagues,
who is very well renowned,
they don't have space,
and they said I should
come talk to you.
And I realized
that person did me
a favor, informed this person
about what I was doing.
They could use their
legacy to say, hey, here's
someone who you might
want to talk to.
That person was my first
graduate student, that student,
and was the first author
of the first paper
and helped me get
my first grant.
And things took off from there.
So I realized very quickly you
have to come out of the office,
you have to engage
at different levels.
The other thing
to do that I think
is very important,
as Julie says,
to keep stock of what
your expectations are,
how you're going
to be evaluated,
how you're going to
be promoted, and get
this sort of general-contractor
group of people.
So I noticed that there's
faculty in my department
who are phenomenal authors,
their papers are always
in the top journals, and
so I kind of went to them
and said, well, could
you read my paper
and give me some advice?
And they would say,
the science is fine,
but the presentation
needs some work
in terms of how you
have to project it
to individuals so they
can understand it better.
And then I realized
something, that I
am the best person to explain
to other people what I do
and why it's important and
why you should promote me,
why you should keep me around.
But if I cannot explain that
in a way that you understand,
I'm doing myself a disservice.
So one of the
things someone told
me is they said, write your
own recommendation letter.
And that's a hard thing to do.
But when your department chair
or someone comes and says,
we want to put this
person up for this,
or you want to apply
for this, and they
say I have to write
this recommendation
letter for this new assistant
professor in my department--
who did we hire again?
What is this person doing?
What have they done in
the last few months?
And you need to be able to say
exactly why that's important.
And so what you
might want to do is
find a colleague who has
had experience with that.
And there's one
thing Julie says--
as you become a
senior person, you
sit on promotion and
evaluation committees.
You have this experience.
Find out who in
your department does
that, because it's someone, and
say, OK, what do I need to do?
Where am I going?
How can I actually
get to this direction?
And that's advice, too, about
not working in the bubble.
One thing I would say,
too, in terms of your time,
in my opinion really
as a Harvard professor,
other than air, water, and food,
your most precious commodity
is time.
It's a limited resource.
There's only so many
hours in the day,
so many days in the
week, and everyone
is going to be
jockeying for your time.
And I'll come back to
how to reserve your time.
So I think that what you
want to get in the process of
is sort of getting a schedule
in terms of what time
you can allot to
specific things.
And one thing I want to
say now and come back to
is the work-life,
home-life balance.
Many of the
assistant professors,
you may or may not
have a partner,
you may or may not have kids.
At some point during the next
decade that may change for you.
And it's very important for
you to kind of set aside time.
And for
And for me, for example-- I
was talking this morning--
I'm a single dad
of twin daughters,
and I have a set amount of time.
I have a schedule.
Everyone in my life
knows my schedule.
They know that Mondays
and Tuesday nights,
I'm free to stay late,
I'm free to work with you.
Wednesdays and Thursdays
I'm with my kids.
Don't call me.
I'm not going to call you back.
If it's an emergency,
you can text me something
or send me something, but
this is my allotted time.
And I think that once everyone
can understand that and say,
hey, this is when
I'm available, they
will respect those boundaries.
The other thing I
want to say, too,
about not working in a bubble is
at some point during your time
here, you will have a crisis.
That is life.
Whether it is a death in
the family or an illness
or basically an accident or
someone you know or something
or your house burns
down, there will
be something that
will take you away
from your focus on
the work that you
will have to go and deal with.
And I think it's very important
that you recognize that that
will happen and to be very
honest to the people around you
and let people know what's
going on in your life.
You don't have to
be an open book
and tell everyone
all your business.
But what I found is I
went through a few crises
and issues I had to deal
with, and by my department
chair and my business
administrator
and people knowing
in general this
was going on, behind the scenes
they kind of kept things away.
I was talking this
morning-- I noticed that I
wasn't getting as many emails.
I wasn't getting as many people
asking me to do something.
Julie knows this.
As one of the few
African-American
tenured faculty
members at Harvard,
I get asked to do
stuff all the time.
And suddenly people
weren't asking me as much.
And that was a
blessing, because people
knew what was going on
in my life, and again,
not working in the bubble.
Also with the promotion
side, one practical thing
that I would tell
everyone to do is at least
every quarter, every three
months, update your CV.
Because what's going to happen
is that next year some time
someone will say, hey, we
want to put you up for this,
or this is going
on, and then you
have to sit down and think
about what am I actually doing.
So just every time you
have a calendar-- well,
I gave this talk, I did this,
I'm writing this article,
I'm writing this
book-- update your CV.
And if you have
nothing to put on it,
if you have nothing on your
calendar that is coming up,
that's a sign that, hey,
I need to kind of get out
of the bubble and go talk
some other individuals.
One strategy for
researchers is that one
of the criteria that
you're promoted by
is your recognition
in the field.
That comes from various
ways-- publications,
presentation, promotions.
You may have to do
some self-promotion.
So for example, some of the
colleagues here at Harvard
are probably world-renown
in the fields that they do.
You might go and say, hey,
if you're on this journal,
I would be willing to be
on the editorial board
for this journal at some point.
Please consider me.
If you are basically putting
this conference together
in three years, you should come
look at the work that I'm doing
and just consider me for
giving this presentation.
Those little things of just
saying, hey, I'm available,
will often very much help you.
Because we're all very busy,
and at the last minute someone
says, I need to do this.
Back when you had cover
pictures on journals,
one of the colleagues in
my department was the cover
editor for the journal and then
basically came to me and said,
I saw that you had an
article in this issue,
and you didn't tell me.
Give me something so we
can put on the cover.
Oh, OK.
That networking aspect works.
So I think that you
want to be aware of what
your colleagues are doing
just in general, because they
can avail you.
The last thing I'll say
is about the tenure.
When I first came here, someone
said, getting tenure means
being able to say no,
that now I've arrived
and now I can tell people no.
And I think that's not the case.
I think getting promotion,
getting to tenure,
having a successful
career means being
able to say no to protect your
time to allow you to accomplish
what you want to do.
So how do you do that?
One of the things about
the general contractor
is to identify people
that can help you.
And you have to identify someone
that can help you say no.
So for example, for me it
was my department chair.
I was asked to do this, I'm
trying to protect my time,
I have a colleague who's
a senior colleague who
I don't want to offend,
trying to do a collaboration
with them.
So I went to my
department chair,
and he says, of course you
don't need to be doing this.
So I said, well, can
I send people to you?
He said sure.
So when someone came
to me and said, Darren,
we want you to do this.
I go, my department
chair says I can't.
You should go talk to
my department chair.
He says, no, he's
not going to do this.
If you have a problem,
you can speak to me.
Problem goes away.
So I think, again, you want kind
of identify the areas that you
want to get to, how
you want to get those,
and who can help you get
to those particular areas.
So I'll stop there, and
we can re-address anything
during the question portion.
But that's kind of my
general sage advice.
And I hope that
applies to everyone
here in terms of what school,
what department, researcher,
teacher.
But I think those could be
very helpful along your path
here to Harvard.
And welcome, and I wish
you continued success
and that we'll be
colleagues for a long time.
And I have to say if this is
the first and last time you ever
see me, that's your problem.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm now one of
those people, right?
We're now one of these
people that you can seek out
for sage advice, right?
Add that to your list now.
[LAUGHTER]
DEVAH PAGER: awesome.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Devah Pager.
So I've just been
here two years now.
I'm a relative
newbie on this panel.
Prior to coming to
Harvard, I spent nine years
at Princeton and before that
two years at Northwestern.
So I have some
comparative perspective.
So some of the
comments I'll offer
will be Harvard-specific
and some more universal
to how to make this
professional life work.
So my first piece of
advice-- I think most of you
are probably just
starting your first jobs
in your first semesters.
Is that right?
How many of you are here
in your first semester
of your first job?
Oh, just a small
fraction of you.
So others of you have
been here for a while now
or are starting-- OK.
Anyway, well, welcome
to all of you,
wherever you're coming from.
I would say if you
have moved here
from somewhere
else, whether this
is your first job or
your second or nth job,
I would plan on your first
semester being a time
for you to enjoy and
settle in and not
plan to really
get any work done,
especially if you're
teaching this semester.
I think the first semester
is really a time for you
to be settling in, learning
where the coffee maker is,
signing up for your
gym membership,
keeping your classes
running smoothly,
figuring out where
you are in the world,
and don't put too much
pressure on yourself.
In a way, the tenure clock is
short, but in another sense,
you need to take a semester
to really settle in.
So give yourself that time.
My advice for the first year
or for the early periods
of your time here
is to really spend
some time finding a community.
And keep in mind that that
community may very well
be outside your department.
I'm talking about an
intellectual community as well
as a social community.
Harvard is a large
and diverse campus.
It's full of centers and
institutes and departments
with all kinds of
opportunities to meet folks.
And this is an opportunity,
especially early on,
to really sample from that
diversity of opportunities.
I think one huge benefit of
turning your life upside down
to move somewhere
new is that you
don't have the same things
that tie you down and get
you stuck in routines
and in a particular rut.
So while you're kind of
unsettled and freewheeling,
take this as an opportunity to
sample from all kinds of things
that you wouldn't
ordinarily select into.
If that means going to talks
in different departments,
going to the university
events like this one,
signing up for
recreational activities,
meeting people from across
campus, I think all of those
really enrich your networks and
will make your time here more
profitable.
When I first got to Northwestern
as a new assistant professor,
all faculty were required to
attend an all-day pedagogy
workshop that was put on
by the teaching center.
This ended up being a completely
worthless waste of time
in terms of the content.
It was just full of really
boring and useless information,
unfortunately.
I think those kinds of workshops
could be done very well.
I hope they do them better now.
But the content ended up
being fairly worthless.
But at this workshop, I
met two faculty members,
one who was a new
professor in the psychology
department, another new
professor in the history
department, who became
two of my closest friends
and remain so to this day.
They were close intellectual
colleagues, as well as friends,
and that was really enriching.
So there's a silver lining
to spending days sitting
and listening to boring
panels-- no offense.
[LAUGHTER]
And there can be
really terrific things
that come out of those events.
So really spend some time early
on developing those networks.
To echo something
that Darren said,
I think you also want to think
about developing community
within your department as well.
And I think cultivating mentors
is a really important part
of that community.
I think most new faculty,
when they enter a department,
some people really take the time
and say, I want to get coffee
or I want to go to lunch.
But the truth is that most
people, especially when they've
been in their rut
and in their routine
and are busy with a
million commitments,
they are thinking to themselves
in the back of their mind,
oh, I'd really like to get
to know this person better,
but they just never are able
to stop and take a moment
and reach out and find a time.
So you should take
that initiative.
And every semester,
make sure that there
are at least one or two faculty
members in your department
that you're reaching
out to and say,
hey, do you want to get lunch?
Do you want to get coffee?
And cultivate some of
those relationships.
Because your colleagues
really, really do
want to get to know you, even
though they're just caught up
in their own little bubble.
My third piece of advice
is to learn to say no.
And more specifically,
I'd say just
say no more often than
you're saying yes.
That's kind of my general
rule, I think, especially
for junior faculty.
Now, of course you want
to be a good citizen,
you want to be a member
of your community,
and your colleagues will notice
that you are contributing
and that you're
pitching in, and they
will appreciate that for sure.
But you can't do
everything, and you
won't get tenure just for
being a good committee member.
So figure out where you
can make a contribution
to your department.
Figure out where you
can make a contribution
to your university.
And do those jobs
really, really well.
But don't get penalized
for doing those jobs well
by getting roped
into participating
on 15 other committees.
So just plan strategically
with your time.
And that goes for professional
activities as well.
So let's face it.
We have awesome jobs,
and we get to do
all kinds of things
that for the most part
are really, really enjoyable.
So I love giving talks
in different departments.
I really like going
to conferences.
I like speaking to
non-academic audiences.
I like meeting
with policymakers.
I like meeting with
student groups.
I like being included in
special edited volumes.
There are all kinds of things
that are parts of our jobs
that we really, really enjoy.
But we can't do all of them.
So how do you figure out what
to do and what not to do?
Well, I have a really, really
great litmus test for you.
So you have to
think to yourself,
when you get asked
to do something,
if you would be willing to
do it next week, you probably
want to do it.
If you wouldn't be willing
to do it next week,
don't do it at all.
So here's my
thinking behind that.
Academics get asked to do
things six months in advance,
12 months in advance, like well
beyond any reasonable sense
of having a time horizon
or what that feels like.
And the temptation is to think,
oh, yeah, six months from now,
my docket will be clear.
Like now is the busy time.
This is the crunch time.
But once I get past
these next few deadlines,
things will really clear out.
But the truth is, what
you are experiencing now,
that's how you feel next
spring and the following fall
and the year after
that and every semester
until you retire.
So if you're too
busy to do it now,
the chances are you'll be too
busy to do it a year from now.
So there are things
that I get asked
to do that if I had
to do them next week,
there's no way that
I would say yes.
And sometimes I get
roped into doing things
because I've been asked a
year and a half in advance,
and then I get to the
point where I actually
have to turn in the chapter
or attend the conference,
and I'm thinking, what
the heck was I thinking?
I really don't want to do this.
And there are other things
that when they come up,
like I really want to be
a part of those things,
and I would clear my schedule to
do them if they were coming up
much more quickly.
So if you wouldn't
want to do it now,
you probably won't want to
be doing it a year from now.
Say no.
OK, last few pieces of advice--
delegate and ask for help.
I think this is consistent with
the general contractor model.
Harvard has a lot
of bureaucracy.
It's probably the most
bureaucratic institution
that I've ever been a part of.
[LAUGHTER]
But in my experience,
staff, from the level
of administrative assistants
all the way up to deans,
are exceptionally
highly qualified
and really, really
good at their jobs
and committed to
doing their jobs well.
And they're there,
for the most part,
to help you do your work better.
So take advantage of that.
Figure out what those resources
are and how they can help you.
There are people that can
help you with data analysis.
help you filing your receipts,
with sending out your
letters of recommendation,
with maintaining
your bibliographies,
with setting up and
maintaining your website.
There's all kinds
of staff out there
that can help you
do your job better.
Sometimes it takes more effort
to ask someone else to do it
than just to do it yourself,
but that's only the first time.
So if there's
anything that you plan
to be doing more than once
even, if it's only once a year,
find someone else to help
you do it and delegate.
And then the last
thing I would say
is keep in mind that everyone
feels like an impostor
at least some of the time.
Your colleagues did not make
a mistake in hiring you.
Unless you are Michael LaCour
and made up all of your data,
there were some very good
reasons that your colleagues
chose you out of what was an
enormous pool of applicants,
I am sure.
So keep in mind what you
love about your work,
and your colleagues are
going to love it as well.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Thank you.
DEVAH PAGER: Yeah.
OK.
So interesting to
hear from all of you.
Questions?
SPEAKER 2: Sorry this is
a negative, sad question.
[LAUGHTER]
But in your experiences, what
are the characteristics--
unscientific observation, fine--
of the people who didn't get
promoted?
We've heard a lot
of the good things
that we should be
doing, but then
like what about the pitfalls?
SPEAKER 3: You ask
negative questions.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Oh, yeah.
My first one was
really negative, too.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE BUCKLER: I can
speak to that briefly.
And then I'm sure my
two colleagues also
have something to say.
In my remarks, I
talked about taking
control of your master plan.
I mean, obviously it's
not a rigid thing,
but the people I've seen
who haven't gotten tenure
have been a bit
hapless about it.
Many times they're brilliant,
but they didn't really
take control over their
process of doing the work
and bringing it to completion.
And so often they were
just too slow to produce
work that could then get
a response in the world,
and so Harvard didn't have the
information it wanted in order
to make that judgment.
The fact that we don't
have tenured associate
rank it means that
you have to look
like a good prospect
as a full professor
at the end of your
junior appointment.
And that's a really tall order.
And you just cannot get there
without really deliberately
making it happen.
So that's my advice.
DARREN HIGGINS:
Yeah, I think for me,
I think it's a
multitude of reasons.
But really, it can come
down to a few things.
One is I think the people
I've seen who haven't been
successful are people who
didn't say no and just got
too distracted and too diluted
in terms of what they were
doing and also maybe had a
different perception of how
they were going to be evaluated
and what that criteria were.
So for example, in
my particular field,
the scholarly production,
your publications,
how people perceive you in the
field, and your research work
was very important.
They've changed the
tracks now in terms
of teaching, et
cetera, but you've
had people who said,
well, I've done
all these other things,
all these other committees,
et cetera, but then when you
look at the promotion criteria,
someone says, that that
didn't really count.
One thing now that they
do is, for example,
the actual letter that
gets sent to the people who
will write your review
of you is available.
That is a specific,
worded letter.
So if you look at
that, it's very clear
what those criteria are in terms
of how you will be evaluated.
The question is
how you get there.
And the last thing I think,
as we all talked about,
is people who didn't
take advantage of saying,
let's go get some assistance
to help me get to this point
and find people who
say, OK, this is an area
that you need to work with.
You may want to get
some more, et cetera,
you may want to do some
more outside work here,
you may have more focus on this.
So let's come up with a
plan on how to do that.
So really it's this
thing I call PPEP,
which is Perceived, Planned,
and Executed to Perfection.
So if you don't perceive
what the challenge is,
how you're gonna get it
and then plan for it,
then you can't execute it.
But if you do that, then it's
not going to be a problem.
And another thing I'll
add, too, is tenure
is not the end-all, be-all.
I've seen a lot of people who
leave this institution well
before that time
frame because they've
been so successful in other
places they get sucked away.
And that's not a
bad place to be.
I've seen people leave and go
to industry because they've
taken that work that way.
I've seen people leave
and go to other aspects,
go start companies,
go do things,
and they've used the time
here to develop that.
So I would just add that thing.
That's not the end-all, be-all.
All if you're enjoying
what you're doing
and happy and productive, then
that's the best place to be.
DEVAH PAGER: Yeah, I
would echo those comments.
And I think the
faculty that I have
seen that have not been
successful have been folks that
have diverted their attention
to other activities that maybe
gave them more immediate
reinforcement but weren't
the kind of scholarly production
that they needed in order
to pass that 10-year bar.
And I think sometimes it's like
the process of writing articles
or books is a long one, and
there's very little feedback,
and you really have to
be extremely patient
and endure a lot
of criticism, where
other things, other
parts of our lives,
even teaching, for example,
where we're getting
immediate feedback and
where we're feeling
like the interaction with the
students is really stimulating
and that is
fantastic-- and being
able to combine
an active teaching
and research life is the
ideal, but in some cases,
you shift the balance
to the thing that's
giving you the most
immediate gratification.
I'll also say that in
addition to the fact
that some people do
leave prior to tenure
and find other things
to do, my sense
is that not getting tenure
at places like Harvard
has a very different impact from
being at other universities.
And so everyone I've seen
both at Princeton and Harvard
who have not gotten tenure have
gotten great jobs at Research
1 universities elsewhere.
So in that sense, this isn't
the only place in the universe
to do good work.
[LAUGHING]
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 4: I just
wanted to follow up
on the comment from
both Julie and Devah
about the adjectives "slow" or
"fast" scholarly productivity
and sort of generally the
nature of productivity.
I would love to hear you
talk a bit-- of course,
it would be sort of
discipline-specific about what
really counts as good
productivity and what doesn't.
Because sometimes
people can think
they're doing the right thing,
and it might not, in fact,
be the best investment
of their energy,
even if they're
intelligently not getting
on 17,000 committees
or not getting
around to doing their work.
So can you say something
about the sort of temptation
to do the wrong
kind of productivity
and the best ways of
judging where your best
input for your energy is?
DARREN HIGGINS: I'll
make a comment to that.
And I think that the best
indicator of future success
is prior success.
And that's a real
issue that you bring up
in terms of doing something
that you may really
want to do that gives you
a lot of gratification
but may not be the best
direction that you might want
to go in terms of
your evaluation
for promotion, et cetera.
And so that's where
I think having people
who are in your mentor checkbox
who have sat on the committees
and been involved in the
evaluation process, who
can look at what you do-- and
they'll ask you point blank,
where are you going with this?
Where do you see this
beginning, middle, ed?
What do you hope
to get out of this?
And when are you going to
get something out of it?
And if someone says, well,
this is something that's
going to be seven
years from now,
and they say, well, you're going
to be evaluated for associate
in five years, this is not where
you want to invest your time.
So I think it's really
getting the benefit of people
who can sit down and
tell you point blank.
You don't want to
surround yourself
with warm fuzzies-- that's
great, that's fantastic,
go do it, yes, yes, yes.
You also don't want
to surround yourself
with people who are just,
oh, that will never work,
don't do it.
You want to find people who
are very pragmatic who can then
evaluate and say,
well, if you do want
to do this here are
the things that you
need to be concerned about.
And then ask yourself, am I
willing to actually do that?
And if the answer
is yes, then you
might want to take that
chance to go and do that.
And if the answer
is no, then that's
a good way to steer you
away from those aspects.
JULIE BUCKLER: Well, I said be
conscious about your decisions.
And by that I mean be informed.
Because it is really such
a challenging balance,
and frankly, it continues to
be challenging at every career
stage now, in my
experience, which
is to say that you have to
push really hard to move things
forward and make them happen.
And especially as a
junior person here,
you really have to work
hard to deliver the goods.
But on the other hand, you
have to live your life.
You do have to
find some balance,
and you can't turn
yourself inside out.
And many of us have other
commitments of various kinds
that are important
to us, or there
are things we also need to
do for our mental health.
So it's really quite tricky.
I mean, it's something
I guess you decide
on a daily basis, which
is why I also advocate
the use of a master plan
so that you can be doing
short- and long-term planning.
And it's a marathon, basically.
You need to be able
to sustain your pace.
And you need to be able to last.
[LAUGHING]
DEVAH PAGER: So I just say
that in the social sciences,
we tend to work on
multiple projects at once.
But the danger is that
it's a much, much more fun
to start new things than it
is to finish older things.
And I think that's a temptation
that needs to be resisted.
So whenever you
start a new project,
you have to be really,
really thoughtful about,
is this the thing
that I'm really
going to commit
to going forward,
or is this just going to
distract me from the work
that I already have ongoing?
And I feel really
strongly about the idea
that there is no such thing
as a quick and dirty project.
So there's often the
temptation to think, oh,
this new issue
came up, or I just
found this new source of data.
I'm going to do this
quick and dirty analysis,
and it's just going to
take me a week or so,
and then I'll write it up, and
it just be a little side piece.
In my experience,
those projects end
up taking just as
long as the projects
that I feel like are really
big and important, or can,
and so keep in mind that
there is no such thing
as that quick energy project.
And I just wanted to say for
me when I'm evaluating files,
I feel like a smaller number of
really important, high quality
pieces is worth so much
more than a long CV
of mediocre pieces.
And so I would invest more
in every single project
or publication
rather than trying
to just stuff your CV full
of less meaningful entries.
JULIE BUCKLER: I just
want to add something.
There was an earlier question
about how to describe people
who were not successful here.
And I am thinking of
a particular example
of a person who was kind of a
writing and publishing machine,
endlessly producing and
publish-- it's actually not
that difficult to place
things and get them published.
But then it's out there, and
the work was kind of shallow.
And now that I'm not
under that same pressure,
I actually publish
pretty slowly,
because I really
don't want my work
to be published unless I
feel it's my very best work.
And so that's another one of
those tensions and paradoxes
about the appointment
at Harvard,
that they do want to
see some quantity,
but you can't be obsessed with
quantity, because it will lead
you in the wrong direction.
I really agree completely
with what you said.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Other
questions or comments?
SPEAKER 5: What do you
do when you get rejected?
JULIE BUCKLER: You mean like
something for publication, or--
SPEAKER 5: A book manuscript,
a paper, a grant proposal.
It's going to happen to
everybody in this room.
And it's one of the
most awful things
to happen to a faculty member.
DARREN HIGGINS:
That's an evolution.
It's funny you say that.
First off, rejection
is part of it,
because everyone has an
opinion, and their opinion
is not going to necessarily
be in tune with yours.
And so in terms of the
rejection, that's a part of it.
My question would be, how
many times did I get rejected?
So for me, the average time that
somebody submits an R1 grant,
and I think it's like four
times before it gets in.
Nowadays, publications,
they get it
rejected at least once
or twice, because people
want to see more.
And so I think you have
to kind of look it as,
what's the rationale
and the reason?
And so for me, rejection
is this is part of it.
Did you put something that
was-- as Julie was just saying,
was it your best effort?
Was it not shallow?
Was it very well crafted?
Great.
If someone rejects it,
why did they reject it?
And I give you three examples.
So sometimes you may
get it rejected because
of the wrong reasons, which
is a competitor saw it,
and they just don't want it
out there for certain reasons.
If it's a publication,
I have a habit now
of what I do is I just
go right to the editors.
And I'll call the person-- and
they love this-- and I'll say,
well, the paper got rejected.
Here are the
reasons why, this is
what I'm willing to
do to improve it,
This is what I think
is completely off base.
What do you think?
And they'll say, oh,
OK, no we can't do that.
Great.
I'm going to send
it someplace else.
Often times, they
will agree with you,
and they say, well, the
reviewer asked you for something
that really is not reasonable.
That's five more years of work.
That's not really reasonable.
So if you don't agree,
I'm not going to do that,
and this is what
I'm going to do.
So the benefit of that is
now when it goes back, we've
addressed all the potential
things so it doesn't get
rejected again.
So it's minimizing
the rejection.
In terms of grant
processes, as I said,
it's many, many times
it will get rejected.
You certainly have a
smaller [INAUDIBLE]
larger amount of times
you can send it in.
The question I
would say is, well,
did you go get the
appropriate advice to see what
are the reasons why?
Is it not scientifically sound?
And sometimes someone
will say, this really
isn't scientifically sound.
We don't think
it's going to work.
At that point, you
may say, I may have
to go to a different direction.
So my answer to that
is really, what's
the reason for the rejection?
And is it based on
something that's grounded?
And what can I do about that?
But rejection is
just part of it.
DEVAH PAGER: Yeah,
you definitely
can't take it personally.
There is so much randomness
in the review process,
in every review process.
And some of my
favorite papers have
gotten rejected by one
of the top journals
and then accepted by the other
top journal in my discipline.
And the reviews just read
the paper very differently.
So I definitely wouldn't take
it personally, and in some cases
I would just turn around
and send it right back out.
There are other cases where
you get the reviews back
and you realize, you know what?
I didn't communicate
that idea effectively,
and at least for this
subset of readers
who are coming from a
different perspective from me,
they need a different set
of evidence or arguments
that's going to convince them.
And then I try to make it
better and get out there again.
JULIE BUCKLER: It's
a learning process.
It seems like whenever I try
to move into something new,
my first attempts
are not successful.
And then I try to figure
it out from there.
But it is disconcerting
to realize that, yes, you
can submit an article to one
of your field's top journals
and have it rejected even though
you're tenured at Harvard.
And it can happen.
It does happen regularly.
So I don't know.
I think thickening your hide a
little bit is good, is helpful.
DARREN HIGGINS:
One thing I'll add
to that is using whatever
the rejection was
for future information.
So for example,
in my field there
are certain study sections
of the evaluation panels
that just don't
like certain things.
And I had this
experiment one time,
which was a great experiment.
I couldn't have
designed it any better.
I submitted a grant in response
to a request for applications,
and they had so many
requests that they said,
we're going to extend
the time for evaluation.
We're going to give 25 grants,
and we have 600 applications.
So we have to extend it.
And they said, so we're
going to suspect this rule,
and you can now submit
the exact same grant
at the same time as this one
to a different study section
and just change the name.
Because we think there's
going to be some great grants,
but we don't want you
waiting around for six months
to get one of these
25 when you could just
go to a regular study section
and probably get it now.
So I said, OK.
So I just changed the
name and submitted it.
So when I submitted it to
the regular studies section,
it was triaged-- boom--
wasn't even reviewed.
This is horrible.
It will never work.
It's not innovative.
It's not creative.
We don't understand why
he's submitting this.
But I got one of those 25
grants from the first one.
And it was the exact same grant.
And what I realized was that
that grant for that study
section that they asked for for
this specific thing was perfect
but for the general
sort of thing
really wasn't as appreciated.
So from now on, whenever I
submit something, I would say,
it needs to be here.
It has to get here, it has to
get in this particular review
panel.
And what I didn't realize
in, and one of my mentors
told me here, was that you have
a right when you submit grants
to have your grant
reviewed in the most
favorable circumstances.
So if it gets sent to a study
section you don't want it in,
you can call up and
say, please move it.
And I didn't realize
that, and I had a grant.
It got rejected, another one.
I called up, and I said,
this is not the right place.
They sent it to the other
one, and it got funded.
So a lot of it is just the
context of who's seeing it,
who's looking at it.
And I just want to add
this one point now,
because this is one of
the best pieces of advice
that I ever got as
a faculty member
at Harvard in the last 17 years.
And I have to credit
my colleague Steve
Lory who told me this.
And he asked me, he said,
how is your stuff going
to get reviewed?
Do you understand how it's
going to get reviewed?
And I said, well,
of course I do.
They get it, it goes
at this study section,
it goes to this panel, it goes
here, it goes here, great.
He goes, no.
You don't you know.
It's not going to get
reviewed that way.
What's going to
happen is there's
going to be somebody who's
tired, who's working all day,
who just had a fight
with their spouse,
whose kid got in
trouble with school,
whose dog got into
the neighbor's yard
and messed it up,
who's mother-in-law
is coming and crashed the car.
And they're going away
for some other meeting,
and they have this
limited window of time,
and they pull out your
paper, your grant,
to read it on the
plane while they're
going to wherever they're
going to before they come back
to everything that's
going on in their life.
So your stuff is going to
get reviewed under the worst
possible circumstances.
So you need to make
sure you understand that
and make sure
everything is clear.
And he just gave the sage
advice of, if I read this page
and I stopped, and then
I picked it back up again
and I looked at it,
what's most important?
Put that in highlight.
Do this.
Every time you start a new
section, repeat the same thing.
If I'm having a conversation and
I interrupt your conversation,
I come back, OK, catch
me up to where I am.
That's how it's going
to get reviewed.
So it's these little
sort of pieces of things
and understanding the realities
of the process which I
think will be very beneficial.
And that's the thing,
because it takes time,
as Julie said, to
understand the realities.
But once you understand that, I
think it becomes more tenable.
Because now whenever
I write anything,
I assume this is going
to be read by somebody
on a plane in the worst
possible lighting with the kid
behind him kicking in the seat.
Because I have reviewed
things in that same way.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 6: Hi.
So let's say you're
in a field which
is very ideologically
polarized with a lot
of political controversy.
Let's say your work
can be controversial.
And that will affect,
of course, reviews.
That will affect
what people are going
to say when they send things
out for tenure and stuff.
How would you navigate that,
sort of knowing in advance
that this is the kind
of field you're in
and there are sort of
big ideological stakes,
there are going to be divides
and angry opponents, things
like that?
How do you navigate
that in terms of tenure?
DEVAH PAGER: So every field and
every department are different.
My advice would be to keep in
mind that affect can overcome
ideology, and you
shouldn't automatically
assume that whatever factions
exist in your department
are immediately going
to be imposed on you.
And so you may have
natural allies,
and you may fit in better
with one set of senior faculty
than another.
But you shouldn't give up
on cultivating relationships
and contact with the
wider pool of faculty,
because if people see you
as a human being, not just
a member of this
warring faction,
I think they're going to be
more invested in understanding
your work and seeing
its contribution
and seeing it in light of
its full scholarly potential
rather than just seeing you as
one part of an opposing army.
So, yeah, that
would be my advice.
JULIE BUCKLER: I think it's
absolutely right that you find
allies in strange
places and at its best,
people practice here this kind
of culture of civility, where
you sit around a table at a
department meeting talking
about a search or some
intellectual issue.
And there are real
differences in views,
and people really care
a lot about the outcome,
and it's quite a
challenge to remain civil
and to keep things
from getting heated
and to stand your ground.
But when it works, it's
such a beautiful system.
You'll see it in operation in
your department and program.
And it's such an
invaluable skill.
It's never a good idea to send
an email when you're annoyed,
to snap one off--
always a bad idea.
And it's always a
bad idea to snap
at a colleague in a meeting.
And you just really have
to have good self-control.
DARREN HIGGINS:
Yeah, I think just
to echo the two things
is the word ally.
I think if you're
going into a field
where there's a lot of political
issue, a lot of contention,
the question is, who are
the most prominent people
that may have some sensitivities
to what you're doing
and how you can actually
change it or direct it?
That gets to the
thing I mentioned
about writing your own
recommendation letter in terms
of being able to clearly
articulate what you're bringing
to the table that no
one else is and how
your view may be productive.
And just focus on the focus
on the positive aspect.
Here is something that may
be able to unify and get
past some of the contention that
you're having and you're having
to come to a unified agreement.
And this is how I'm
going to approach it
and how I'm going to do that.
And I think as starting someone
new, that actually a benefit.
My own personal
experience, there
was a little bit
of warring factions
in my group between
the Americans
and the French and the Germans.
And then this Canadian scientist
came in and collaborated
with all of us secretly--
[LAUGHTER]
--and then published his
paper with everybody on it
that we then realized, like wow.
And then we said, this was
someone who came completely
from a different field, who
really changed our thinking
and was able to overcome
this sort of entrenched
political squabble.
And we realized, yeah, this
person did us a service.
So I think if you
can position yourself
in that way, that's
a way to overcome
that initial angst of moving
into a direction that way.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Well, that
was really very informative.
Thank you to our three
panelists for joining us today.
[APPLAUSE]
And now Judy will provide
some closing remarks.
JUDITH D. SINGER: Thank you.
Well, actually, thank
you all for being here.
It means a lot of us to
see all these new faces
and to think about what
the faculty of the future
of Harvard is going to be like.
And also thank our
colleagues here
for taking the time and
our prior colleagues
for taking the time.
Essentially I just want people
to get to know each other.
So I think we're going
to provide a break time.
But you have heard
some themes here
that I just want
to reiterate-- some
of the phrases of
having a master
or being the general
contractor of your life.
I always say have a
mission statement.
And part of that
is being strategic.
Time is short.
And so I think a lot
of the questions,
a lot of the comments
were about ways
in which people try to be
strategic about their time
and their energy
and their resources.
Another part is, learning
to say "I don't know"
is one of the hardest things
for a Harvard faculty member
to say.
Because we selected you.
We expect you know everything.
And you know something?
You don't.
And so whether it's
learning to say
"I don't know" to a
student, when it's learning
to say "I don't
know" to a colleague,
when it's learning to say "I
don't know" to a colleague.
"Can you give me some advice?"
And then never only
ask one person.
Because if you only
ask one person,
you'll be convinced that
that person just gave you
the right answer.
And chances are
that person didn't.
So learning how to ask
questions is something that
has come up time and a time.
And reaching outside
of your boundaries
is something that we're
very interested in.
I've had the pleasure reading
most of your dossiers.
So a lot of the work that's
done by the people in this room
increasingly is
interdisciplinary.
And so learning how
to cross boundaries,
but also being strategic and
not crossing so many boundaries
that you're splat
on the floor and you
haven't done the kinds
of strategic things
that you need to be successful.
And if the success
leads to tenure, great.
If it doesn't, at least
you'll be true to yourself.
And so being successful and
strategic and time management--
I think several people
said that's probably
the most important thing.
Learning to say no is
about time management.
Being proactive is
Instead of waiting to
see what committees
you're asked to be on, think
about what the two things you
want to do are, go
to your department
chair or your
academic dean and say,
these are the things
that interest me.
They're perfectly
happy to figure out
how to work around that.
So instead of just waiting
for things to happen,
being proactive and having
that align with your mission
becomes another way to think
about being successful here.
I'm going to close
it out by just
saying there are going to
be a lot of other events
the semester.
Some of them you've already
gotten e-mails about.
We have an event at
the Houghton Library
at the end of the month.
The Houghton library is a jewel
box on the Harvard campus.
It's the rare book collection.
[INAUDIBLE] Menand from
the English department
is going to be giving a talk.
You're going to be
able to go and touch
Emily Dickinson's desk.
And you can pick out books,
first editions, notes
by various authors.
You can think about
your favorite author
and go find the papers that
he or she might have given.
So I encourage you to join us.
There will also be
a publishing event,
where we're inviting editors
from Harvard and MIT Press.
And we've got a book agent.
So if you're interested,
if you're in a book field,
learning about the book world--
even if you're not yet there,
it just sort of
gives you an idea
about it issues involved
in book publishing.
On the fun side, we've got
bank of tickets for the ART
in December.
We hold a reception
at the ed school,
which is right across from the
American Repertory Theater.
So I encourage you
to join us for that.
I hold lunches for tenure-track
faculty during the year.
So we've got a whole
bunch of things planned.
We often do things
on social media,
on op-ed writing about
getting your voice out there.
So we're always
looking for ideas.
So if you have any
idea about something
you'd like to learn
more about, chances
are you're not the only person.
Let Elizabeth-- Elizabeth
there conveniently
have the same name--
or me know, and we'd
be happy to steal your idea and
magnify it for other people.
So why don't I stop here?
We have a reception upstairs.
You can go check
your email and do
all of those kinds of things.
Hang out in the lobby,
or just hang out here.
Or come up to the
reception to meet.
We have about another
30 or 40 people
coming from across
the university.
So I just want to say thank
you very much for joining us.
And I look forward to meeting
every one of you and talk.
My goal is to know every
Harvard faculty member.
I'm actually not bad
at it at this point.
So I look forward to
talking to all of you.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]